[Music]
this is Tsar's Cove - it belongs to the
family of coronaviruses named for the
crown like spikes on their surfaces
Tsar's Cove - can cause Ovid 19 a
contagious viral infection that attacks
primarily your throat and lungs what
actually happens in your body when you
contract the corona virus what exactly
causes your body to develop pneumonia
and how would a vaccine work the corona
virus must infect living cells in order
to reproduce let's have a closer look
inside the virus genetic material
contains the information to make more
copies of itself a protein shell
provides a hard protective enclosure for
the genetic material as the virus
travels between the people it infects an
outer envelope allows the virus to
infect cells by merging with the cell's
outer membrane projecting from the
envelope are spikes of protein molecules
both a typical influenza virus and the
new corona virus use their spikes like a
key to get inside a cell in your body
where it takes over the cells internal
machinery repurposing it to build the
components of new viruses when an
infected person talks coughs or sneezes
droplets carrying the virus may land in
your mouth or nose and then move into
your lungs once inside your body the
virus comes in contact with cells in
your throat nose or lungs one spike on
the virus inserts into a receptor
molecule on your healthy cell membrane
like a key in a lock this action allows
the virus to get inside your cell a
typical flu virus would travel inside a
sac made from your cell membrane to your
cell's nucleus that houses all its
genetic material
the coronavirus on the other hand
doesn't need to enter the host cell
nucleus it can directly access parts of
the host cell called ribosomes ribosomes
use genetic information from the virus
to make viral proteins such as the
spikes on the virus's surface a
packaging structure in your cell then
carries the spikes in vesicles which
merge with your cells outer layer the
cell membrane all the parts needed to
create a new virus gathered just beneath
your cell's membrane then a new virus
begins to butt off from the cell's
membrane now with the virus spreading in
your body how can you develop pneumonia
symptoms for this we'll have to look
into your lungs
each lung has separate sections called
lobes normally as you breathe air moves
freely through your trachea or windpipe
then through large tubes called
bronchioles called
bronchioles and finally into tiny sacs
called alveoli your Airways and alveoli
are flexible and springy when you
breathe in each air sac inflates like a
small balloon and when you exhale the
sacs deflate small blood vessels called
capillaries surround your alveoli oxygen
from the air you breathe passes into
your capillaries and then carbon dioxide
from your body passes out of your
capillaries into your alveoli so that
your lungs can get rid of it when you
exhale your Airways catch most germs in
the mucus that lines your trachea
bronchi and bronchioles in a healthy
body hair like cilia lining the tubes
constantly push the mucus and germs out
of your Airways where you might expel
them by coughing normally cells of your
immune system attack viruses and germs
that make it past your mucus and cilia
and enter your alveoli however if your
immune system is weakened like in the
case of a corona virus infection the
virus can overwhelm your immune cells
and your bronchioles and alveoli become
inflamed as your immune system attacks
the multiplying viruses the inflammation
can cause your alveoli to fill with
fluid making it difficult for your body
to get the oxygen it needs you could
develop low burn pneumonia where one
lobe of your lungs is affected or you
could have bronchopneumonia that affects
many areas of both lungs pneumonia may
cause difficulty breathing chest pain
coughing fever and chills confusion
headache muscle pain and fatigue it can
also lead to more serious complications
respiratory failure occurs when your
breathing becomes so difficult that you
need a machine called a ventilator to
help you breathe these are the machines
that save lives and that medical device
companies currently ramp up production
for whether you would develop these
symptoms depends on a lot of factors
such as your a-agent whether you already
have an existing condition while this
all sounds scary the push to develop a
corona virus vaccine is moving at high
speed studies of other corona viruses
led most researchers to assume that
people who have recovered from a SARS
co2 infection could be protected from
reinfection for a period of time but
that assumption needs to be backed by
empirical evidence and some studies
suggest otherwise there are several
different approaches for a potential
vaccine against the corona virus the
basic idea is that you would get a shot
that contains faint versions of the
virus the vaccine would expose your body
to a version of the virus that is too
weak to cause infection but just strong
enough to stimulate an immune response
within a few weeks cells in your immune
system would make markers called
antibodies which would be specific for
only the corona virus or specifically
its spike protein antibodies then
attached to the virus and prevent it
from attaching to your cells your immune
system then responds to signals from the
antibodies by consuming and destroying
the clumps of viruses if you then catch
the real virus at a later stage your
body would recognize it and destroy it
in other words your immune system is now
collecting evidence on whether this will
be possible safe and effective is part
of what's taking researchers so long to
develop a vaccine it's a race against
time to develop a vaccine amid a
pandemic each step in vaccine
development usually takes months if not
years an Ebola vaccine broke records by
being ready in five years
the hope here is to develop one for the
new coronavirus in a record-breaking 12
to 18 months while all this will take
time stay home if you can to protect the
most vulnerable and don't forget to wash
your hands for at least 20 seconds and
as often as possible
now what would happen if you didn't do
that for an entire year well that's a
story for another what if hey there
Peter here I'm recording this in my
basement today as we continue to self
isolate social distance I hope you are
too we want to say a special thanks to
nucleus medical media today for those
cool 3d animations if you want to see
more scientifically accurate medical
animations head on over there channel
you learn more about the human body
conditions and illnesses and how we can
treat them you know it's only science
that's gonna get us through this stay
safe everyone